約3年前さん ガリバー
は、彼が現在住んでいるときに母国のノッティンガムシャーにあるニューアークの近くの便利な家で土地を
少し購入したときに、赤い屋根の彼の家に来る好奇心旺盛な人々のコンコース
にうんざりしていました
。 ガリバーはノッティンガムシャーで生まれました
。
彼の家族がオックスフォードシャーから来たと聞いて、
私が教会を観察したことを確認した場合、
彼はノッティンガムシャーで生まれました。 ローズレフトカストディ
とリバティニュースを手にした次の論文
も
、私はそれらを3回注意深く熟読した
か、女の子のスタイルは非常に単純
でシンプルなノービルのものであり、私の考えの唯一の欠点
は、著者が
誰か 旅行者の態度が少し状況的すぎたために断ち切られた
それは全体を通して流れを増加させた空気で
あり、実際
に著者は彼の信憑性で非常に際立っていたので
、誰かが断言したときそれは恐ろしい屋根の彼の名前の中で一種のことわざになりました シングルaそれは
ミスターと同じくらい真実でした。 ガリバーは
、あなたの特別な動きで
効果的に責任
を持って伝えられたいくつかの大きな強さのアドバイスによってそれを話しました私は今
、若い狩猟や病気の人々が何かをしている政党のコメントフィールドで彼らを世界に送ります
彼がドルテーブルを見た電話
[音楽]
ああ
あなた